- This is just straight fucking facts.
99.9% of people that you
judge or have opinions on,
you have no idea what the fuck
is actually happening in their lives.
Let's just start there.
The fact it, you probably only know
what four or five people
actually have going on,
and even then, you don't know as much
about your sister or your
parents as you think.
So who the fuck are you?
(synth music)
You've got your perspective.
(synth music amplifies)
(camera shutter clicks)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you wanna be happy?
(light synth music)
- I do.
- It's offense.
I think people say "no" too often,
because they fear ramifications.
I don't think micro losses are scary,
and empowering people to make
decisions is how you scale.
And to me, I've always thought that
somebody doing an 86 instead of my 100
is better than not doing it at all.
Plus, how am I ever gonna
learn if somebody's capable
without giving them a chance?
Like, eventually you have
to let your kid swim.
Eventually you have to
let them swing the bat.
And so, yeah, I'm completely
not driven by fear,
and people are, and the reason people
don't let people do
things is they fear it,
or they have, I mean, it's ego.
A lot of people don't
want their understudies,
or their direct reports,
or the people they manage
to be better at something than them.
It's just insecurity.
I'm massively secure in myself,
and that's exactly right,
Caleb, that's a good insight.
You're doing a good job with this
in asking me this questions.
Like, I say "yes," I give trust at first.
You can lose it.
People are like, "Trust is earned."
I'm like, "Cool, that seems
fucking slow and egotistical.
"Like, who the fuck am
I to have it earned?"
You know, like, great.
Like, fuck that.
To me, trust if given,
and then you lose it
if you're a dickface, uncapable,
incapable, excuse me, and have proven that
you're not worthy of the
challenge or the role.
I think one thing I've noticed, though,
that is a counteract to my
move, is that a lot of times,
when you accelerate that too
soon, people become entitled.
They, in the micro, get a little
bit of high on their supply
and they think they're big shit.
And they start having egos underneath you,
when you weren't like, watching my people
that I empower with like,
I trust you blindly,
then not trust people
blindly underneath them,
is heartbreaking, happens often,
and is something I'm thinking a lot about.
- I don't.
I prefer to see what people
actually do naturally themselves
than try to micromanage it.
I think a lot of people never
get a true read on somebody
because they've
over-manipulated their tasks,
and the person is doing
exactly what that boss wants.
And to me, ultimate
scale is allowing people
to roam free and expose themselves.
It's kind of like that rope, right?
I'll give you rope,
and you can go forever,
or you can hang yourself with that rope.
I think that whatever that analogy is
that I've heard in culture,
I'm sure, is what I'm doing,
which is, I'm giving
unbelievable amounts of rope,
and some people will run
into perpetuity with it,
and create enormous amounts
of happiness, and wealth,
and success in whatever we do together,
and others will, you
know, get tripped up on it
and get caught up in their
bungee cord, and lose.
- Well, first of all, I have always been,
you know, an alpha, and I have
always led with gratitude,
and empathy, and kindness,
and compassion, and caring.
That doesn't always manifest
in my content or on stage,
you know, when I have the lights
on and I'm my most showman.
But, I mean, that's become very obvious
to anybody that's close to me.
And I believe that because the
world is harder to hide from
that, over time, people will
develop better people skills,
because that has always been
the thing that mattered.
But in a world that you could
hide behind closed doors,
non-Internet, non-media
at everybody's fingertips,
people went to bad behavior.
And so, yeah, I think
emotionally intelligent
characteristics, and what I
would call soft, and caring,
and fluffy, and warm,
and cuddly, and cute,
I think are actually enormous
strengths for an alpha male.
And I do think of it a lot like
the color pink and the color blue.
The color pink was a boys' color,
and the color blue was a girls' color
in the late 1800s, early
1900s, and it was rebranded.
And I think that, you know, in the 1980s,
you know, tough, and don't show emotion,
and don't show weakness, and all that,
were the kind of like,
Marlboro Man, John Wayne era.
And I think that the way I roll
is going to be the next era.
Now, I'm probably both, right?
Like, I can be kind of like,
aggressive and competitive,
and show that side, but
my absolute strength
and foundation to my success,
and often other people's
that I admire from afar, are
predicated on their empathy,
and perspective, and
gratitude, and warmth.
And you know, I think I'm winning on that,
and I think I'm gonna make it popular,
and I think a lot of people are gonna
feel the benefits of good.
- I mean, emotional intelligence for me,
I define emotional intelligence
in the ability to be empathetic,
the ability to feel others,
the ability to be the
bigger person emotionally
because you are not
chemically or perspectively
thinking about things in the short term,
and you're able to take a step back
and, in the the heat of
the moment, bring value.
And I think just feeling people.
You know, just feeling people,
and then knowing what to do with it.
There's emotional intelligence,
and there's the ability to then,
and the fine line, turn
that into manipulation,
because you feel people,
and you're able to
move them into something
that doesn't benefit them.
And I think some of the
worst people of all time
have been emotionally intelligence,
have had emotional intelligence,
but they transformed it into
a negative manipulation.
You know, and my ambition
is to go the other way,
which is to use my emotional intelligence
to create an incredible force of good.
And I think emotional intelligence
is a little bit more
complex than just charisma.
You know, I think a lot of times
I'll use emotional
intelligence or other things.
I genuinely believe there's
a conversation to be had around kindness.
You know?
Being kind.
It works.
- [Off Camera] I'm noticing it. (laughs)
- It works.
But I think there's also like,
you know, I think one thing
that people don't understand
is I think I use being misunderstood
as an advantage to get it accomplished.
So let's talk about how you set this up.
So there's always gonna be a group
that believes in me right away,
and there's a group that
doesn't believe in me.
And then there's the middle,
which the biggest group of all.
I think for a lot of those people,
they're gonna gravitate towards,
you know, I always say people
find what they're looking for.
So I feel like the people that
most appreciate my content right away
are either optimistic and
positive in nature to begin with,
so they see it, or love candor, right?
And then there's people
who are just cynical
because they've been hurt,
or negative, 'cause they're negative.
And I think those people
struggle with me at first,
but I do think being misunderstood
or having very polarizing reactions to me
is a strength of mine,
because I can slowroll people
into where I'm looking
to get them mentally,
in my own selfish
ambition to like, do good.
I'm not hung up on it.
Like, whether I'm right
or your buddies are right,
like, somebody's gonna
be right in the end.
(laughs) You know?
Like, spending time debating
if I'm a good dude or not,
if I'm really real or not, you know,
if I'm full of shit or not,
is utterly a complete waste of time.
- [Caleb] Boom.
- Boom.
I'm just fucking gonna do, and just like,
the score will be the score.
Didn't matter if you though
LeBron was gonna be good or not.
Like, LeBron took care of that.
And people will still say
what they're gonna say,
so I'm okay with that.
- I don't judge other people,
and it starts with myself,
and it's a very powerful thing.
Of course I judge people,
but I don't judge them.
I guess, of course, let me rephrase.
Things run through my minds, opinions,
but judgment is final.
It's absolute.
And I just think everything's
in a work in progress,
or moments in time, or angles, or context,
or you need to know so much more.
Like, everybody's got opinions on people.
They don't even, first of all,
this is just straight fucking facts,
99.9% of people that you
judge or have opinions on
you have no idea what the fuck
is actually happening in their lives.
Let's just start there.
The fact it, you probably only know
what four or five people
actually have going on,
and even then, you don't know as much
about your sister or your
parents as you think.
So who the fuck are you?
I mean, that to me is just like,
I just have no interest in being so wrong.
I care too much about myself
to judge other people. (laughs)
Like, you don't know me, and
that means I don't know you.
And so, you know, everything
is within context.
Everybody's so absolute, you know?
World is gray.
YouTube, I hope you enjoy that.
The new guy, he's emerging.
Understand it.
Leave a comment under two cents
if you understood this episode.
And please, subscribe,
subscribe, subscribe.